let's say you don't like company ABCD
very much and you're convinced that the
stock is going to go down so in that
situation you can actually short you can
actually short the stock which in a very
high level is a bet that the stock is
going to go down and the way that you do
that mechanically is that you borrow the
stock you borrow the stock from someone
else who owns it and then you
immediately sell that stock that you
don't even own you sell the stock that
you borrowed from someone else and
you'll sell it at the current price so
for example in this situation you would
sell it you would sell it at the current
trading price of $50 you would then hope
that the stock price goes down so in
this situation let's take think about
the situation where the stock price goes
down so if you shorted it right over
here you borrow the stock and you sold
it for $50 and then if the stock were to
actually go down let's say it goes all
the way down to 20 and you think that's
about how far it's going to go down then
you can buy back the stock you can buy
the stock you can buy the stock for $20
in this situation and then give it back
to the owner you had borrowed the stock
now you can hand back the stock to the
owner so you can give it back and you've
essentially unwound it and what it
allowed you to do is it allowed you to
do the buying and selling in reverse
order normally before you sell something
you have to buy something but here
you're able to sell it and buy it later
for a lower price so in the situation
where the end price is $20 you had sold
it for 50 so you got $50 and then you
had to use 20 of it to buy it back so in
that situation you would have shortened
the stock you would have made you would
have made $30 let me write this column
here this is the shorting this is the
short option you sold at 50 you borrowed
and sold at 50 then when it went down to
20 you bought it back you bought it back
for 20 so you had $50 of proceeds you
have to use 20 of it to buy it back so
you had a $30 profit but that's only in
the good scenario what happens if your
bed is wrong what happens if the stock
price goes
to 80 and over here you get so scared
you're like oh my god I have to buy this
stock back by 81 if it keeps going up I
can lose an unlimited amount of money so
over here you get scared and you unwind
your situation you say okay I'll go and
buy the stock for $80 so I can give it
back so in this situation where the
stock goes up you actually can lose a
lot of money you had sold it for 50 so
you only have $50 that you have from the
transaction but now you have to buy the
stock for 80 so if you sold for 50 and
you buy for 80 you've now lost thirty
dollars your thirty dollars in the hole
so now you are at negative negative
thirty dollars and really shorting is
the riskiest of all of the things you
can do because a stock price can go
unbelievably high what happens if the
stock price goes to $800 it goes to
$8,000 you all of a sudden you've you've
sold something for 50 and you have the
obligation at some point in the future
because you have to give the stock back
of paying $500 or $800 or $8,000 you
don't know how much you'll have to lose
so it's really the riskiest thing you
can do but it is one way to bet that a
stock price will go down or profit from
a stock price going down